hi this is Michael fur deck CEO and
founder of reputation khammam here in
Vienna the web event for Central Europe
and Asia very invigorating panel
discussion today that I was I was very
lucky to be on about the innovation that
we can have in the personal data space
the title of the panel was rethinking
personal data data as the new oil if all
the data in the world that are being
generated on the internet all the time
about each one of us are oil kind of the
new lubrication of a new economy how do
we create value for the end user how do
we created a user centric world in which
every person can control more of his or
her data and then actually monetize it
for his or her own benefit very exciting
discussion with representatives from
telecommunications from civil society
from academia and also from law
enforcement some terrific discussion
from the audience and I've been very
impressed with how the World Economic
Forum has taken a leadership role in
this very important issue on a global
basis not only here in Vienna but in
other sessions that the web has been
having all around the world see you
later